prince william and prince harry are
coming together to honor their late
grandfather prince philip
in a memorable way i think everyone's
hope is that this is going to be
an opportunity for william and harry to
spend some time together
e.t has learned that the duke of
edinburgh who died earlier this month
is currently lying at rest in the
private chapel in windsor castle
on saturday the coffin will be moved
privately from the chapel to the inner
hall
and on the day of the funeral the coffin
will be moved in a ceremonial procession
from the state entrance windsor castle
to saint george's chapel
i think um royal duty is extremely
important i think it's some it's
part of the um part of the fabric of of
what
the royal family and any future monarch
has et has also learned that while
prince william and prince harry will
both be participating in the ceremony
they will not be standing next to one
another peter phillips the son of
princess anne will be standing between
william and harry
as the brothers walk behind phillips
coffin the estranged brothers have not
seen each other face to face in quite
some time
certainly not since harry's shocking
interview with oprah winfrey last month
where he and wife meghan markle accused
an unnamed member of the royal family
of expressing concern about the
potential color of their son archie's
skin
before he was born royal expert katie
nichols says everyone is hoping this
unfortunate moment will bring the
brothers close once again
they haven't actually seen each other
now for over a year
you know zoom conversations telephone
conversations simply
aren't the same as being together so
this is the first real opportunity that
they are going to have
to sit down together and talk
and hopefully start to
build a better relationship the
congregation will also be wearing masks
and members of the royal family will be
in morning coats with medals
or a day dress there will be no military
attire
the ceremony will also include a maximum
of 30 guests including prince philip's
widow queen elizabeth
prince charles and his wife camilla and
kate middleton e.t spoke with royal
expert omid scobee
shortly after philip's death he says
this is the way the late prince would
have wanted his life to be honored
if there's one thing that we know about
prince philip is that he really does not
like fuss and he made that known when it
came to planning
his funeral as well he worked closely
with the lord chamberlain's office
at buckingham palace to ensure that it
wasn't a blown-up
affair so this will really give a chance
for the royals to remember his life in a
very peaceful and quiet way
he also reveals this will be a very
bittersweet moment for harry
who got married to meghan markle in the
very same chapel prince philip will be
laid to
rest that really highlights the
importance
of the venue so george's chapel is a
royal family chapel and so many moments
have happened there
there are monarchs from the past buried
at that chapel
there are many great memories from
family christenings
and also weddings of the past so it's a
place where family history runs deep and
ultimately on the day of prince philip's
funeral it will be a celebration of just
that
a family